how is dating different in Australia to
here I I don't know I have been someone
who's a very long-term relationship
person so I've been in like full serious
relationships pretty much my whole life
and I've never someone who like dated a
bunch of people in between it was more
so I've never been on the apps I've
never been about any of that life it's
more so just organic and people who I
meet to like my day-to-day life was this
in
Miami which part the long-term
relationship oh uh one of them yeah I'm
you're in a relationship yeah no but
when like once you got here did you find
I was already in a relationship so we
were already dating for like nearly 2
years and then we moved here and we were
dating for like another year and a half
so I've been single for about the last 6
months okay so impossible to find
boyfriend I